Queens New York is the most ethnically
diverse urban area in the world with
over 150 countries represented and 138
different languages spoken a subway fare
can transport you almost anywhere in the
world and that means that there is a lot
of great food to be eaten here a lot
[Music]
Flushing Queens is one of the largest
Chinatown's
in the world and here you can find a
dish that stands out due to something
special its color
[Music]
Pavano handle Hanyu languages
Maharashtra vs Honda for immense joy or
Helen or the TNT entrance also easier to
lose a point in santa chiara baman TF
Allison on languages Valhalla sure Romeo
nagua Jose each other being here bien
sûr FISMA how shiny whole Pergamos ruler
chosen for me it wasn't a share from the
competitors and some friends on
counselor Joe so Lola
Tommy initially jung-eun or ebay Odeon
theatre returns how much our whole suit
and also if I answered a whole I will
kind of language what a sound with no
coupon and watch others ago buy into the
me Anthony via me if any be insulting
and wahida giant circle how Susheela
whether you come home over in Jackson
Heights we head south of the border and
find a flavorful seafood dish in a very
unlikely place
[Music]
tiene la gente Cerullo Delarue well when
I in control nedeli has the indiana's
estamos who become hostile apart and el
fondo de latina
mean ombre stylo Rodriguez me negocios
en la esquina del Cameron Meccano yes
OVA colony Nevada and Jackson Heights
Queens el producto principal son los
hoteles de cámara de los ingredientes
ke-eys cameroon poco de lima some clam
juice la salsa de tomate a case el
secreto hace con el cocktail cilantro
Segovia waka and western la salsa de
tomate el mas especially un poquito
Maharaja Hari Busan hello Kelly well
toka special as the people a cocktail
empezamos
vendian una parte de fuera solamente
sabado C Domingo perón D a tener un
restaurante mal Grande no creo que si el
mejor estoy seguro que el mejor
[Music]
in Corona there is a stand embracing the
flavors of the South Pacific and
bringing back an old street food
tradition
[Music]
I think your cereal you were the only
one currently making this is a straight
dessert that disappearing from the
street of Indonesia my name is Nigel
silica my stand is called moon men were
currently in the fish market in corner
near City and we also available
everywhere near City
coconut pancake is the traditional
dessert sweety sent from Indonesia
instead of rice flour coconut milk and
fresh coconut we cooked them in the
griddle and then once it turns into a
hockey puck we let it cool a little bit
ready somebody in the room temperature
and then we sprinkle a little bit of
sugar and then we flew towards it it's a
creamy on the inside and we'll equality
on the outside me and my cousin Chris
grew up with this a snack and then we
can find it in New York City but we
cannot miss it so we decided to make our
own in a different part of Corona near
the 7 train is a small shop serving up
extremely large tortas
[Music]
Paulo regulary todo tipo de restaurante
has been a pequeñas obvious la grande
para sell go de diferentes mi nombre del
vino Molinaro me negocios yama tortas
Nessa Samos we cousin away this is
considerable Avenue ah who knows paso de
la parada del tren johnson bulevar de
transitive la TARTA women teleport me
when you'll adore tapu Madiba a my
janessa lechuga tomatillo huacatay
jalapenos diva a vocal chorizo c'mon Sal
chicha
Emil and a sad poem Iike see yo tiene
todo el Cigala Mexico una Delicia nos
para una persona al menos que tenga
Mucha hombre es aproximadamente res
libras hasta ahora todos es una Delicias
oh no tengo ninguna ketchup or ESO por
que vas a la gente c'è una de guerra
preguntar por lo mismo lo mismo lo mismo
que buscar una variedad de la Kelin
contra moose finally back in Jackson
Heights in an area called little Nepal
we feast on a traditional dish bursting
with flavor and history she don't give a
more than tumbling in love cheese has
become even stronger mothers in I am NOT
looking name investors in an email me
last year
I know Momo dated another drug addiction
ah la la
get a stretcher up here and some
happiness
no more discussion here virtually a lake
in the knowledge Amazon and for which a
la voce' laundry captivity la mola
centuries in the Caribbean toward
account of a chisel Manoa commercial
core engage seat angle neurons on the
Coto de Caza profit Samadhi cello washes
rhetorician the champagne
[Music]